last week a film that had been grabbing
headlines for reasons that have nothing
to do with the film itself finally
premiered Olivia Wilde's don't worry
darling is from what I've read a sort of
feminist fever dream of a film a woke in
the extreme and yet of such low quality
that most movie critics have actually
panned it despite agreeing with and
applauding its politics now fortunately
for the critics Olivia Wilde is white
and I think straight and so they're
allowed to criticize her work you know
they're a lot they're actually allowed
to do that and so in this case they have
the movie had a relatively strong debut
at the box office
helped by all of the news coverage it
had gotten due to gossip and drama
behind the scenes the details of which
are too tedious and boring to bother
recapping here but sales began tumbling
a few days after the release as
audiences realized that the film is
garbage and word began to spread
um it's sort of unfortunate in a way you
know Hollywood finally puts out a movie
that isn't based on a comic book or some
other pre-existing brand
and it sucks so I have a feeling the
industry will learn all of the wrong
lessons from this outcome
but months before the film came out uh
Wilde had explained that the villain in
the movie is based on Jordan Peterson
whose excellent content by the way is
now available on daily wire plus uh
Wilde said that Peterson himself is
quote a hero to the in-cell community
which she defined as quote
disenfranchised mostly white men who
believe they're entitled to sex from
women and they believe that Society has
now robbed them that the idea of
feminism is working against nature and
that we must put back into the correct
place
she then accused Peterson of quote
legitimizing certain aspects of their
movement because he's a former Professor
he's an author he wears a suit so they
feel like this is a real philosophy that
should be taken seriously
now almost everything that
you can hear in that quote there is
false and stupid it's like a seven layer
cake of wrongness just totally
ridiculous on multiple levels but how
does Jordan Peterson himself feel about
it well he was asked about it um by
Piers Morgan last night while he was uh
visiting uh Piers Morgan's show and
here's what he said watch
and what I'll ask you just quickly the
film director Olivia Wilde has a new
movie out which she says is based on you
this insane man this pseudo-intellectual
hero to the in-cell community in cell
being these weirdo loner men uh who are
despicable in many ways is that you are
you the intellectual hero to these
people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
I thought the marginalized were supposed
to have a voice
is making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are
and certainly many young men are in that
category and you get these casual
insults these these in cells is what do
they mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them when she said that Olivia Wilde
it stung you didn't it oh by that time
you know
that as far as as critic critiques go
that was kind of low level I mean once I
got painted as
Red Skull you know magical super Nazi
that was kind of the end of the insults
now Peterson has been trending today
because of that clip with the thousands
of leftists mocking him for becoming
emotional and slightly teary-eyed media
headlines from Outlets like variety
declare Jordan Peterson breaks down in
tears when asked about Olivia Wilde
calling him the hero to the incel
community now the headlines are of
course meant to stir up even more
mockery and they also are meant to give
the false impression that Peterson was
crying over the insult from Olivia Wilde
no obviously is not the case he makes
queer that he doesn't care what Olivia
Wilde says and why would he does anyone
he became emotional when speaking about
disaffected despairing young men
those were tears of empathy
not self-pity okay this was not a Taylor
Lorenz type crying fit it wasn't it was
it was in every way the opposite
but this is an interesting thing that
you might notice
the left constantly insists that men
should be less stoic should show more
emotion
and then when a man does exactly that
and shows emotion he's ruthlessly
ridiculed for it so they say that men
should be vulnerable but the moment that
any man actually takes them up on it his
vulnerability is wielded against him
used against him
and if men notice that this is how it
works and thus resolve to be even more
closed off and reserved they'll be
accused of toxic masculinity it's it's a
game that men cannot win because no
matter what they say or do no matter how
they react to any situation they lose
and that is really the point isn't it
Jordan Peterson has noticed the ways
that our culture Stacks the deck against
young men isolates them disenfranchises
them alienates them
he speaks with empathy to and about this
group of people and that's the primary
reason why he is hated so much by the
left people like Olivia Wilde have made
it clear that young men should be
lectured and nagged and are treated with
disdain
we should make no attempt to understand
them least of all guide them and
Champion them well we can't do that
and that's why anyone who does so any
figure who comes along and tries to give
alienated young men a voice
and thus earns a large following of
exactly those kinds of men is going to
get kicked off social media D platform
villainized Etc we've seen this play out
countless times not just with Jordan
Peterson
and can you think of an example of a
public figure who is garnered an
audience who's known to have garnered an
audience largely of men and yet has not
been labeled controversial because of it
the message is made loud and clear
you may ignore these people
or you may demonize them
but you must not treat them with respect
or advocate for them or try to
understand them
because if you do that you're a danger
you're a threat
you're a hero to the in-cell community
of course we have to keep in mind that
whenever anyone on the left uses the
term incel they simply mean
all men who are not a vowed woke
leftists that's what an incel is it is
at this point nothing but an anti-male
slur used against literally any man
who's judged to be a political enemy you
don't need to gather on 4chan and you
certainly don't need to be an
involuntary celibate to earn the title I
mean they use that term against me and I
have a wife and six kids if you could be
an in cell while driving your family in
your 12 passenger van to church then the
term obviously has a much broader
meaning
it's just another way another label
meant to stigmatize and alienate
and it works
because
no matter what you think
no matter what image you have of the
world
no matter what your politics or your
ideology demands you believe
no matter how deeply you believe in the
fiction of male privilege the fact is
that a huge number of men in our culture
especially young men are deeply lonely
lost
frustrated
isolated
I mean I hear from these men every day
Jordan Peterson hears from them at an
exponentially greater volume that's why
he gets emotional when he talks about
the issue because encountering the
depths of other people's despair every
day takes a toll
I mean it's an enormous burden
an emotional burden that sociopaths on
the left can't understand I mean they
they literally can't understand empathy
when they see it they just laugh at it
because they don't know what else to do
with it
but it leaves us again with this Stark
fact that these men exist
and denying that they exist only
contributes to the problem
but it's it's easy to see why the left
doesn't want to acknowledge you know the
societal crisis of marginalized
disenfranchised young men because for
one thing the left has this complicated
uh ever-changing victim pyramid to
maintain and a victim pyramid requires a
villain you know with all those victims
around we need someone to do the
victimizing
men especially white men have been
assigned to that role but much as comic
book films don't usually spend too much
time humanizing their super their super
villains for fear that they might you
know become too sympathetic and then
you're not going to root for the good
guys anymore so too does the left avoid
humanizing their own chosen villains and
for the same reason
that's why they treat it like a big
secret like no no you're not these
people aren't human beings okay no no no
we have we we can describe these people
in one sentence and you're not allowed
to go beyond that sentence
but I think there's a deeper reason also
why they would prefer to ignore this
group
and that's because young men and young
women in this culture are suffering from
Despair and hopelessness and purpose
purposelessness
because this is what the sexual
Revolution and our culture's continued
Lurch leftward has brought
you know if you acknowledge the men if
you take their pain seriously
then you've opened a conversation that
the left doesn't want to have
because it's a conversation about how
how all of their promises have been
empty
their Revolution failed
I mean they created despair where they
promised happiness
and uh emptiness where they promised
fulfillment
that's why these men must continue to be
ignored
and anyone who speaks for them
silenced that'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you on Monday
happy flannel Friday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]